Hi.
I'm Pete LePage,
a developer advocate at Google.
>> And I'm Cameron Pittman,
a front end course developer at Udacity.
We're here to help you create
websites that look and
feel great, no matter the device.
>> In this course, you'll be learning
basic guidelines, that make sites look
great across the dozens of
different devices in use today.
>> So Pete you're the expert.
What are websites like Google News
doing to look so good on every device?
>> That's a great question.
Google news uses two
different strategies.
A fully responsive version for
phones and tablet's.
And for desktops it uses a responsive
layout that starts at a minimum size.
That works well for
them, but adds a layer of complexity and
extra work to keep things up to date.
>> Hm, that's interesting.
Right, I know there are a lot of
different ways to accomplish good,
responsive design.
What about websites like Skinny Ties?
>> Yeah, Skinny Ties was fully
responsive across all devices,
laptops and desktops.
This is my preferred
way of building sites,
because it means no matter what
device the user's on now, or
in the future,
my site's probably going to work well.
>> Nice.
You know, that makes a lot of sense.
>> Great, then let's get started.
>> Cool.